oh hi my name is leonel and i will say
anymore we're from Caracas Venezuela to
see the oppressor cities often and learn
more about German culture and history
come with us it'll be an adventure I'm
sure you'll enjoy it let's go
I'm gonna call merry christmas market I
can't miss that there's lots to see
meet up but it's really cold I don't
know what the temperature is I think
it's one or two Celsius some pretty
severely frenetic main difference to
Venezuela there it's always 30 degrees
here you need a hot chocolate it's this
audio
you
all behind this is the famous Cathedral
of often they are dumb
when you imagine about 30 Kings work
round here I think that is 30 Kings
masses of history DoDEA bottom on dome i
sent it was something special for us
about this place
impresionante impressive for you I get
the shivers standing in front of
Charlemagne sarcophagus look I only knew
it from books he thought it and now I'm
standing in front of it here in aachen
cathedral killer might never have
imagined it I know I can like a tile
did something easy puppets are
interesting they look as if they were
for children but adults like them as
well entertaining and Anita
it's so cold
imagine the Town Hall
oh look these are the cookies called
Pinton that we've been looking for all
day and heard so much about a knockin
specialty Venezuela should get to know
them homo Aaron es su ella tiene que
conocer esto
Tim I ruffin now we get to make some
print in ourselves bring them now
now I have to dress down to print it
down you can never try okay yes okay
yeah we know why they're called printed
because you press the cookies into the
shape delicious whoo it's excellent day
fabulous it was super the cathedral the
town hall and then the crowning touch
bring the printing thanks often and it's
excellent city Thank You Germany will
come back every time a young people
hotel choose